In pretty much all of
the videos so far we've
been assuming an economic
ideal, and that economic ideal
is perfect competition.
And perfect competition
is exactly what
you think it is, competition.
But what I want to
do in this video
is think about it in a
little bit more exact terms,
in terms of what are
the ground rules we need
to have to really have this
ideal perfect competition.
It's important to realize that
there's very few markets that
are truly perfectly competitive.
And those that are are
very good for consumers,
but there are that get
very close to being
perfectly competitive.
And if we have time, we will
discuss those in this video.
Now, to be perfectly
competitive,
you have to have
many competitors.
So one of the first
stipulations is many players.
And they need to be competing
for the kind of the same buyer
and kind of offering
the same thing.
And so they need to
have identical products.
Remember, we're talking
about an economic ideal here.
There's very few markets where
the product is absolutely
identical or the service
is absolutely identical,
but we're talking about an
economic ideal over here.
The next condition you need
is no barriers to entry.
So, if at any given
moment it looks
attractive for other people
to go into that market,
other people will
go into that market
and there's nothing that's
really going to stop them.
If the firms that are
already in the market
are making an economic profit
that means that it's good.
It's a good option
for people to do.
You can do better in this market
than your opportunity costs,
and so people will
enter into that market.
And in order for this market
to be perfectly competitive,
we can't have any barriers,
nothing stopping those people.
On top of that, there
can be no advantage
for established firms.
No advantage for existing firms.
So once someone
jumps into the fray
and, assuming that they
are somewhat competent,
they are going to be able to
compete on kind of equal terms
with the people that
are already there.
And then the last one,
and this is important,
is that you have to have
really good price information.
That the buyers
and the sellers all
have to know about
each other's prices.
The buyers need to know all the
prices so that they can really
do good comparison
shopping, and the sellers
need to know everyone's
prices so that they can really
match prices really well.
So good price information.
Now, there are many
different types
of markets that
somewhat approximate
perfect competition.
There are very few that
are completely purely
perfect competition.
But one of them that does
come to mind, one of them that
does definitely come to mind
is the US airline industry.
And the US airlines--
We can think
about these different
bullet points,
how closely it matches it.
There are definitely
many different airlines.
They don't offer
identical products.
I'm sure the airlines
would not agree.
They would say that
they're differentiating
on their service and what type
of food they give or, I guess,
don't give to you,
or how much they're
charging for the baggage
check-in and all the rest.
But for most consumers,
they're just like, look,
I just want an
economy class ticket
from San Francisco to New
York, and they view them
as almost identical products.
So the airline industry
does pretty well
on this first point.
No barriers to entry?
Well, there are some barriers to
entry in the airline industry.
You need a few billion
dollars that you
need to either find
or borrow or whatever,
so that you can buy
the capital so you
can start operating planes.
Or, I guess you could
rent the planes.
But, either way, you
need a lot of capital
to get into this business.
You need access to
airport terminals
that you'll have to
lease and landing
rights and all the rest.
So there are some
barriers to entry.
But for the most part, at
least in the United States,
if you are a US
operator-- so there
are some barriers
to entry, especially
for foreign operators.
But if you are a US operator
and you have the capital
you will be able to be the next
Virgin America or Southwest
Airlines or JetBlue.
So there are some barriers
to entry, but they are low.
It's not like the
government is saying
that no one else can
start a new airlines.
No advantage for
existing airlines?
Yeah.
That's somewhat true.
If I start a new
airlines tomorrow
and it's offering comparable
rates and comparable service,
I could imagine people would be
willing to take this airlines.
So the airline industry
seems pretty good there.
And good price
information-- and this
is why the airline industry
definitely came to my mind,
because I can't imagine an
industry where you have better
price information that at least
now, after the internet came
about-- than in the
airline industry
you want a flight from
San Francisco to New York,
you go to any of these
travel sites, Orbits, Kayak,
Expedia, whatever
you want to go to.
And you get all of the
flights listed for you
and they're listed by price.
They consort them by price.
And you can actually
pick-- and it's
known that people do this--
they pick a flight that
might be $500 or
$600, but they can
compare based on a few
pennies or even a few dollars.
So there's extremely
good price information.
And, obviously, the sellers
have all of their IT systems,
the airlines have
all their IT systems
to keep track of where airline
prices are going as well.
So the air travel industry,
like most industries,
is not absolutely
perfect competition,
but it gets pretty close
to perfect competition.
And you even see that
in the real world,
is that it's very
hard for the airlines
to make really a lot of
profit, whether you're
talking about accounting
profit or even economic profit.
And you can see that from
this supply and demand curve
right over here.
So on this axis, the horizontal
axis, this is the quantity.
This is a measure
of the quantity
of kind of airline service.
And we're measuring
it in billions
of seat miles per
week, and I know
that sounds like
a strange thing.
But really, we're
just saying, OK,
in a given week tell me all
of the seats that are in use,
and multiply those
number of seats--
so the seat miles
in a given week.
The number of seats
times the miles
or the average miles per
seat in a given week,
and that gives you
how much air travel.
This is a measure of air
travel in, let's say, in the US
in that week.
And on this axis,
this is the price.
This is price per, and
this should actually
say price per seat mile.
And, of course, you have your
supply curve right over here.
This is your supply curve.
At first, to start providing
those first few miles.
The airlines are willing to do
that relatively inexpensively.
Maybe they're finding that
from the most obvious airports
that maybe the landing
rights are cheaper
or it's cheaper to lease
things, or whatever.
But as they start running
more and more and more
routes, maybe between smaller
and smaller cities, maybe
smaller and less
efficient planes,
it starts to become more
and more expensive for them
to supply those
incremental miles.
And obviously, on
the demand side,
if air travel is
very, very expensive,
very few people are
going to want to travel.
There is going to be very
little travel that happens.
If it's very cheap, many people
are going to want to travel.
Now, let's say that this is
where the market is right now.
Obviously, we have an
equilibrium price right
over there.
And then we have an equilibrium
quantity of seat miles.
But let's say that the price
level in order for the players
to actually have an economic
profit is over here.
So it is right over here.
So this is the price needed
for zero economic profit,
or you could say for
neutral economic profit.
Or you could even say
for normal profit,
for economic profit
to be equal to zero.
So at that point, if
that is the price, then
the firms that are
offering airline travels,
they're kind of neutral between
shutting down and continuing
to offer service.
But notice, the way
I've drawn it here
that is substantially lower than
the current equilibrium price.
So what this is saying is
since the current equilibrium
price is a good bit
higher than this,
or it's just higher at all,
these firms in the market right
now are generating
economic profit, definitely
positive economic profit.
So what's happening?
If there is positive
economic profit,
that means that there's an
incentive for other firms
to enter into this industry.
So what's going
to happen is this
is going to be the supply
curve right at that moment.
But as soon as another
carrier realizes
that they can, or
any of the carriers
realize they can offer
more-- it doesn't even
have to be new
carriers entering.
It could be existing carriers
just offering, maybe buying
more planes or
offering more routes.
Then maybe a little
bit later the supply
curve shifts like this.
The supply curve
shifts like that.
And then this would be
our new equilibrium price.
But we're still
making economic profit
because our new
equilibrium price
is still higher than
the price needed
for zero economic profit.
So still more people
will continue to enter.
And so then you might
have a new supply
curve that looks like this.
And now this is our
new equilibrium price.
And notice what's happening.
We're traveling down to the
right along the demand curve.
As more supply comes
on, we are obviously
increasing the quantity and
the price is going down.
But still, the
equilibrium price is
higher than this
line right over here.
So even more people
will enter, until we
get to that point
right over there.
And at that point, now
the equilibrium price
is the price at which
all of the players
are having zero economic profit.
And there's no incentive
for more people
to enter into it, because then
the equilibrium price will
go down, or they're,
essentially right
now economic profit is zero.
So everyone is neutral
in this scenario.
So I want to leave you there.
This is what happens
with perfect competition.
That there's no
barriers to entry
and more people go in and in
and in, the price goes down,
the quantity will go
up in this scenario.
But what I want to
do in the next video
is to think about
what if we didn't
have perfect competition.
And especially,
what happens if we
have something
like, I don't know,
something like a monopoly.